여기서는 단일 qubit gate만 사용하니까 어떤 면에서는 사소한 내용이지만, 어쨌든 이런 가젯은 오류를
전파시키지 않아요. 물론 이런 가젯에서 개별 gate 중 어느 하나가 실패할 수 있고, 그러면 오류가 생기지만,
모든 가젯 직후에 항상 오류 정정을 수행해요. 오류율이 충분히
낮다면, 오류 정정 코드가 그 오류들을 정정할 거예요.
앞서 말한 대로, 이건 모든 안정자 코드에서 Pauli gate에 대해 항상 가능해요.
다만, 구현하려는 논리적 Pauli 연산에 맞게 가젯에서 올바른 Pauli gate 패턴을 찾아야 해요.
2-qubit gate를 포함하는 또 다른 예시를 볼게요. 이번엔 CNOT gate의 횡단적 구현을
살펴볼 거예요. 특히, 모든 CSS 코드에서 CNOT gate를
두 논리적 qubit 사이에 구현하려면 단순히 대응하는 물리적 qubit 쌍에
CNOT gate를 수행하면 돼요. 이건 횡단적 조건을 만족하는데, 각각의 개별 CNOT gate가
각 코드 블록 내의 단일 qubit 위치에만 작용하기 때문이에요. 예를 들어, 첫 번째 CNOT gate는 각 코드 블록에서 맨 위 qubit에만 작용하고,
두 번째 CNOT gate는 위에서 두 번째 qubit에만 작용하는 식이에요.
이 경우에는 오류 전파가 발생할 수 있어요. CNOT gate는 오류를 전파하고 그걸
막을 방법이 없거든요. 하지만 핵심은 오류 전파가 절대 하나의 코드 블록 내에서 일어나지 않는다는 거예요.
예를 들어, 가젯이 수행되기 직전에 위쪽 코드 블록의 맨 위 qubit에 X 오류가 발생하면, 가젯 안의 첫 번째 CNOT이
그 오류를 아래쪽 블록의 맨 위 qubit으로 전파해요. 하지만 결과로 생긴 두 오류는
이제 서로 다른 코드 블록에 있어요. 따라서 가젯 이후에 수행되는 오류 정정 단계가 그 오류들을 개별적으로 정정할 수 있어요.
각 코드 블록 내에서 단일 qubit에만 영향을 미치는 오류니까요.
반면, 오류 전파가 같은 코드 블록 내에서 일어난다면 문제가 될 수 있어요.
오류 전파가 저가중 오류를 코드가 처리하지 못할 수 있는 고가중 오류로 바꾸기 때문이에요.
이 구현 방식은 비CSS 코드에는 통하지 않지만, CSS 코드를 사용하는 한 항상 이런 방식으로 CNOT
gate를 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있어요. 한 가지 더, 모든
Clifford gate는 steane 코드에 대해 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있어요. 사실 어떤 색깔 코드에 대해서도 가능해요. 색깔 코드의 정말 좋은 점 중 하나인데, Hadamard gate는 논리적 qubit에
각 물리적 qubit에 Hadamard gate를 개별적으로 수행하는 방식으로 구현할 수 있고, 논리적 S gate는 각 qubit에 S gate가 아니라
각 물리적 qubit에 S dagger gate로 구현할 수 있어요. 결론적으로, 횡단적 gate 구현은 본질적으로
내결함성이에요. 하나의 코드 블록 내에서 오류를 절대 전파하지 않기 때문에, 오류 정정 단계가 이 가젯에 사용된 gate들로 인해 발생하거나 전파된
오류들을 정정할 기회를 가질 수 있거든요. 정말 좋은 방식이고,
내결함성 가젯을 구축하는 아주 단순한 방법이에요. 또한 T gate 같은 다른 gate의 횡단적 구현을 허용하는
다양한 코드들이 있어요. 하지만 안타깝게도, 비자명 코드로는
범용 gate 집합을 횡단적으로 구현하는 게 불가능해요. 이건 Eastin-Knill 정리로 알려진 사실이에요.
더 기술적으로 말하면, 코드의 거리가 적어도 2 이상인 한 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있는 gate들의 집합은
전역 위상을 제외하면 반드시 이산적인 연산들의 집합을 생성해요. 따라서 이 집합은 범용이 아니에요.
범용 gate 집합은 반드시 무한히 많은 연산을 생성하거든요. 이 정리의 증명은 설명하지 않을게요.
이 증명은 이 시리즈의 전제 조건이 아닌 리 군과 리 대수에 관한 기본 사실들을 사용하거든요. 하지만 기본 아이디어는
횡단적 연산의 무한한 族이 코드 공간 내에 머물 수 없다는 거예요.
횡단적 연산의 미세한 차이는 코드가 오류로 감지하는 저가중 Pauli 연산으로 잘 근사되기 때문이에요.
따라서 gate를 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있을 때는 정말 좋아요. 하지만 어떤 코드를 선택하든,
이 방식으로 구현할 수 없는 gate가 항상 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 그래서 대안적인 가젯을 찾아야 해요.
Eastin-Knill 정리에 따르면, 거리 2짜리 양자 오류 정정 코드에 대해서조차 횡단적으로 범용 양자 gate 집합을 구현하는 건 불가능해요.
따라서 적어도 일부 gate에 대해서는 내결함성 방식으로 구현하는 다른 방법을 찾아야 해요.
잘 알려진 방법 중 하나는 소위 magic state를 이용하는 거예요.
이 논의를 위해, 화면에 나와 있는 대로 정의된 S gate와 T gate를
떠올려 봐요. 두 가지를 확인해 볼게요. 먼저 S gate는 Clifford 연산이에요.
Clifford 연산의 정의에서 따라오는 건데, Pauli 행렬을 S로 켤레 변환하면 항상 플러스 또는 마이너스 다른 Pauli
행렬이 나온다는 걸 확인할 수 있어요. 그리고 두 번째로, T gate는 Clifford 연산이 아니에요. 실제로 T를 Hadamard와 CNOT과 결합하면,
둘 다 Clifford 연산인데, 범용 양자 gate 집합이 돼요. 따라서 T gate를
Clifford 연산과 표준 기저 측정만으로는 구현할 수 없어요. 하지만 실제로 T gate를
Clifford 연산과 표준 기저 측정으로 구현할 수 있어요. 화면에 나와 있는 상태의 복사본이 하나 더 있다면요.
그 상태는 플러스 상태에 T gate를 적용한 거예요.
화면에 나와 있는 그 상태, 즉 플러스 상태에 T gate를 적용한 거예요.
이 상태를 magic state라고 해요. 이게 유일한 건 아니지만요.
magic state라는 용어는 이 변형 방식 전체에서 비슷한 역할을 하는 다른 상태들을 가리키는 데도 써요.
예를 들어, 여기 보이는 circuit이 그 역할을 해요. 확인하는 게 그렇게 어렵진 않아요.
윗 시스템을 오른쪽에 두고 초기 상태가 있어요. CNOT gate를 적용하고 정리하면,
여기 나와 있는 상태가 돼요.
아래 qubit을 측정해서 0을 얻으면, 이건 확률 1/2로 일어나는데, S gate를 적용하지 않고
출력은 s에 T를 적용한 결과예요.
1을 측정하면, 이것도 물론 확률 1/2로 일어나는데, S gate를 적용하고, 결과는
출력이 또다시 s에 T를 적용한 거예요. 그런데 이게 유일한 방법은 아니에요. 비슷하게 생긴
circuit들도 같은 작업을 수행하지만, 이건 한 가지 방법이에요.
이건 4강에서 언급했던 양자 gate 텔레포테이션이라고 알려진 것의 다소 단순화된 예시예요. 텔레포테이션을 이용해서